Now...
we are going to take an
uncomfortably close look
at a befuddling online trend,
in a segment we call
@midnight Deep Dive.
(cheering and applause)
The Internet, it has something
for everyone...
to masturbate to.
MARTINDALE:
That's true.
Nowhere is this more true
than on Amazon,
where Amazonian authors
produce digital stories,
where humans get it on
with dinos, gryphons,
and all manner of beastie,
both historical and mythical.
BELLI:
Aw.
But the master of the genre
is a mysterious figure
named Chuck Tingle,
who, since 2014, has written
over 80 micro-novels
with titles like,
Space Raptor Butt Invasion,
or Creamed in the Butt
by My Handsome Living Corn.
(laughter)
-I'm listening.
-Yes, me, too.
And my favorite, Happy Birthday,
Frankenstein, Now Pound My Butt.
(laughter and applause)
That's not Frankenstein.
That just looks like '70's Hulk.
I don't know what that is.
Comedians, what is a line
that you might read
in this amazing erotic
horror tale?
Willam.
(bleep) me so hard Gene Wilder
could feel it.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
(laughter)
Uh, Bridget.
Fire, bad!
Paying attention to balls, good!
(laughter)
HARDWICK (laughing):
Points.
Just... Justin.
It's that show, it's that show.
HARDWICK:
It's that show, that's fine.
Uh, Frankenstein violently
ripped off his own head
so he could easily
suck his own (bleep).
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
Well, that's what you do if you
have a removable head.
I mean! I mean!
And now the reclusive Mr. Tingle
is incredibly prolific,
-churning out super...
-BELLI: Dad!
-There he is.
-(laughter, applause)
There he is.
(whooping, applause)
But who is Chuck Tingle?
No one knows and it's driving me
(bleep)ing bananas.
I have combed his books
for clues, for research.
-I've had...
-(laughter)
I've had my entire staff here
scour the internet.
I even went to the pet store
and shoved a gecko up my butt,
hoping he'd appear, but the only
thing that happened...
But the only thing that happened
was that I could not
stop ejaculating,
and I saved 15% or more
on my car insurance.
(laughter and applause)
But...
Here's what we do know: His name
is most likely a pseudonym.
His author photo
is some kind of stock photo
-from a stock photo site.
-(comedians exclaiming)
So comedians, what's a title
for a PowerPoint presentation
that might use
these stock photos?
-Bridget.
-Oh, that looks like life
after your wife takes
the kids away.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
Uh, Willam.
Tae Kwon No Thank You.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
Justin.
Dying alone and how to do it.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
So...
The eagle-eyed Tingle detective
will find some clues
on his YouTube channel.
So let's take a still
from the trailer for his book,
Buttception, of course,
that book we love, which...
MARTINDALE:
You mean there's more?
There's a lot more, Justin.
There is so much more.
So Buttception features a house
with the address 703.
I'm sure you guys remember, 703,
so here's where it gets weird.
Listen, listen.
This is serious.
MARTINDALE: Here's where
it gets weird, okay.
-Here's where it gets weird.
-The house, the house.
-HARDWICK: This is the weird
part. -I'm listening.
Chuck has trolled men's rights
activist Vox Day,
who once appeared
on the podcast,
The Tom Woods Show,
episode 703, all right?
In his videos, Tingle also wears
a bag on his head,
just like the performance art
piece by Shia LaBeouf,
who is often lusted after on
Twitter by @MaryJane703,
who lives where?
In Alexandria, Virginia,
area code 7-0 (bleep)ing 3.
-MARTINDALE: Oh!
-There is more.
I know, I know.
Scoop your brains back
into your heads,
because you're gonna need them
to process this (bleep).
If that doesn't blow your minds,
of the 703 people watching this
show, then how about this?
In the 50th edition of the
Catholic University Law Review,
we found a case that has to do
with sodomy on page 703.
The name of that case?
Bowers versus Hardwick.
-Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
-Wow!
-I'm in this, too.
-(laughter) -Uh-uh. -Uh-uh.
First of all, I was innocent.
Second of all,
the only explanation
that I have, uh,
is to be the subject
of his next book.
So comedians, what should be
the name of my Tingle story?
Willam.
Jingled Out by Singled Out,
Part Two.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
-(cheering, applause)
-Very good. Bridget.
Uh, Tingle Me Elmo,
Chris Hardwick Gets Soft.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
(laughter)
(applause, cheering)
(as Elmo): Somebody must've
gotten in cold water.
Uh, Justin.
Action Figures
I've Sat On, On Purpose.
HARDWICK:
All right, points. Points.
Uh, so you can see I'm very
passionate about this, so,
-I would like to talk
to Chuck, himself. -What?
Chuck...
Chuck, if you're out there,
I admire your prolific nature,
uh, and insane creativity.
And I would like nothing more
than to be the subject
of one of your erotic yarns
that you spin on the Amazon.
In fact, I'm gonna give you
a (bleep) cover image
to start the process.
Can we set the mood?
-Disco ball, all right?
-(whooping)
I need some...
I need some dino-hunks.
Can I get some dino-hunks
in here, please?
I'd like some dino-hunks.
(cheering and applause)
♪ ♪
Thank you.
Yes, very good.
(laughter, cheering)
This is for you, Chuck.
This should get
your creative juices flowing.
Put me on your book.
Go write your masterpiece.
Guys, I would like you
to tweet Chuck Tingle.
All right, tweet Chuck Tingle,
and tell him Chris Hardwick--
be very specific--
Chris Hardwick deserves
to have his butt pounded
by some weird creature,
or object.
Make it happen.
We'll be right back
with more @midnight.
(cheering and applause)